[Música]
[Aplausos]
algunos de los que estáis aquí habéis
descubierto a vuestro cantante favorito
hace aproximadamente dos años
puede haber algunos y de los que lo
habéis descubierto hace poco ese
cantante llevaba 55 años cantando hay
alguien aquí
ya que no sabéis de quién se trata
rafael y bueno porque esta pregunta me
la han hecho últimamente mucho porque si
para empezar para ser raphaelista con
todas las letras hacen falta años de
duro entrenamiento incluso décadas pues
a mí me vino de manera expresa de hacer
acción porque pues muy fácil porque fui
por primera vez a un concierto suyo y lo
que yo vi ahí me cautivó
para siempre
a mí que siempre me ha gustado mucho la
comunicación ese concierto hizo rescatar
mi predilección por la comunicación no
verbal para que os hagáis una idea ya
chaplin charlot siempre ha sido un
referente para mí
y bueno como os decía la transmisión lo
no verbal que yo vi en ese concierto me
maravillo y lo hizo tanto que acabé
escribiendo un artículo científico sobre
la comunicación no verbal de rafael y es
que puede un cantante contar una canción
sin necesidad de cantar
es posible que un cantante transmita
completamente el contenido de sus letras
sin necesidad de abrir la boca sin usar
el instrumento de trabajo que es la voz
por rafael demuestra que si él expresa
sin necesidad de voz y mira que tenemos
aquí lo tenemos más chulo que un ocho
desde una foto a la otra han podido
pasar 40 años
este artista lleva cantando desde los 4
añitos y de manera profesional desde los
16 años se ha subido a lo más alto y
desde que se subió allá por los 60 no se
ha bajado de la cresta de la ola bueno
se bajó un momentito le trasplantaron el
hígado y volvió a subirse
tiene un disco de uranio su propio museo
que se puede visitar hace giras
mundiales que duran meses con la actual
lleva creo que año y medio y se la ha
solapado actuar actual año y medio tiene
75 años aunque él dice que tiene 23
vosotros en algún momento de vuestra
vida habréis cantado y bailado canciones
suyas cantado y bailado habéis ido a una
buena fiesta y ha sonado rafael y lo
habéis dado todo pero es que también
habéis ido a karaokes y habéis buscado
canciones de raphael para cantar
lo que también es seguro que habéis
visto es alguna parodia o imitación suya
eso es seguro y es que rafael es un
caramelo para los imitadores de hecho
vosotros de manera casera habréis creído
imitar a rafael cuando realmente lo que
estaba haciendo era imitar al gran
millán salcedo
parodiando a rafael que son cosas
diferentes
bien y es que cuando uno es excesivo
puede conseguir grandes metas
si eres apocado pocas cosas consigues
y es que como sabéis aparte de por su
extraordinaria voz a rafael se le conoce
por su gesticulación por su manera de
expresar es en definitiva un histrión y
que es un histrión pues es un actor
teatral o persona que se expresa con la
afectación y exageración propia de un
actor de teatro
esta afectación en los inicios de su
carrera le supuso algunos problemas
porque en los 60 en españa esa
afectación y exageración se equiparaba
amaneramiento y en los 60 aquí ser o
simplemente parecer homosexual estaba
muy mal visto
aquí se estira más lo crooner esto es el
estilo de frank sinatra de manolo
escobar que cantaban mucho y muy bien
pero sin desabrocharse la chaqueta y
rafael era todo lo contrario pese a las
críticas como es tenía muy claro que
quería hacer y como lo quería hacer
siguió cantándole al amor y al desamor
con su estilo algunos fans me dirán lo
estrella le ha cantado a muchísimos más
temas no solo al amor y al desamor si le
ha cantado más temas pero el 90% de las
de más de 700 canciones que tiene
grabadas sin contar las versiones de las
mismas más de la más del 90% de esas 700
canciones son del amor y el desamor
sino si queréis hacer una prueba cuando
estéis pasando un mal momento amoroso no
escuchéis ni a rafael ni a camela
una broma sabéis que a rafael a camila
hay que escucharlos siempre
el estilo de este artista yo lo comparo
con otros
con el greco vemos un cuadro de el greco
y decimos eso es el greco te puede
gustar más te puede gustar menos o te
puede no gustar pero lo reconoces porque
lo identificas porque te llama la
atención y qué le pasaba al greco no
sabía pintar tenía problemas en la
visión mentira pintaba así porque le
daba la gana porque quería porque él
decía a ver venimos de ver las
maravillas que he hecho
leonardo da vinci miguel ángel yo no me
puedo parecer a ellos yo tengo que
destacar tengo que pintar a mi manera a
mi manera de ahí vienen los pintores
manieristas y yo creo que rafael
consciente o inconscientemente tuvo este
pensamiento yo no me voy a aparecer a
nadie y voy a seguir con mi manierismo
raphaelista
bien ahora va a ayudarme con esta charla
un paisano mío o mejor dicho otro
paisano mío puesto que rafael es andaluz
es de linares de jaén que también por
ahí está un poco más justificada esa
vehemencia que tiene o que tenemos los
andaluces a la hora de expresarnos pues
mi paisano más cercano geográfico pero
no en el tiempo es gustavo adolfo
bécquer escritor romántico y porque era
un romántico pues evidentemente porque
él captaban le escribían al amor y al
desamor pero lo hacían de una manera
especial muy apasionada tenían los
sentimientos a flor de piel y ahora
quiero que me acompañéis a un sitio muy
bonito que hay en sevilla que se llama
glorieta de baker o glorieta de los
enamorados está del parque maría luisa y
porque os traigo esta glorieta pues
porque en ella aparte de ver a baker y a
cupido que cupido aquí tiene las podía
ser el papel del maravilloso escritor de
cabecera y compositor de rafael el
jerezano manuel a
pues aparte de ver a baker y a cupido
vemos los cuatro estados del
enamoramiento por el que se puede pasar
cuando está enamorado cuando estamos
enamorados
el primero el amor deseado
está ella coqueta mirando a quién se le
acerca tiene una posición más dinámica y
en movimiento es una estatua pero tiene
una posición más dinámica que el resto
de sus compañeras la siguiente es
el amor poseído que está encantada de la
vida está casi en éxtasis al lado está
el amor perdido tiene actitud con la
mirada caída en los brazos caídos el
pecho hundido está francamente triste
pero es que además este monumento
representa el amor traicionado vemos un
ángel que tiene una daga clavada en el
costado bien creéis que somos capaces de
identificar estos cuatro estados del
enamoramiento tan gráficamente en la
interpretación de una canción sin
escuchar la música ni al cantante
vamos a verlo os voy a poner varios
ejemplos evidentemente no en orden para
que tenga algo de misterio
de canciones y solo al final vamos a
escuchar unos segundos tanto de música
como de voz
quiero que presten mucha atención a todo
lo que es comunicación no verbal es
decir todo lo que vais a ver vale las
luces si tiene bailarines y sobre todo
al cuerpo cara y manos de rafael que al
vestir de negro se transforma
prácticamente en un mimo vamos a ver el
primer ejemplo
a ver vemos qué contento contento no
está se lleva la mano a la cara como de
vergüenza de la espalda al público
atención al cambio de luces
rojas pasión enfado traición tienen los
puños encogido los hombros encogidos los
ojos cerrados no lo está pasando nada
bien este hombre va a acabar en morés yo
llorando
[Música]
rey
mientras que
el sol hola
[Aplausos]
[Música]
le ha faltado a clavarse la daga
amor traicionado la canción era payaso
ven vamos a ver otro ejemplo porque la
mejor rafael todo lo canta igual o le
gusta más interpretar canciones triste
vamos en el siguiente ejemplo
bueno a ver aquí lo vemos más jovencitos
mira cámara no lo veo yo tan triste
no está triste sigue mirando a cámara
mantiene la mirada significa algo
vemos que evidentemente la actitud
corporal es completamente diferente a la
anterior al mirar al cielo nos recuerda
el amor poseído verdad a la segunda dama
yo no estoy segura vamos a comprobarlo
realmente sí
está completamente encantado de la vida
como la segunda dama
en este momento mi amor
el amor
[Aplausos]
[Música]
con las puertas
no vendo perdón
[Música]
y hacia la luna evidentemente vamos a
ver otra canción os apetece
vamos a ver esto
se peina se peina coqueto
esto como de nerviosismo
escucha algo de violines parece ser y va
a dejar cantar al público con la canción
es muy famosa está dejando cantar al
público las luces se vuelven
completamente locas y va a haber
dinamismo y desplazamiento por el
escenario hemos dicho que coqueto y
desplazamiento dinamismo amor deseado
pozo
puede ser
[Aplausos]
[Música]
y vamos a ver otra canción más a ver qué
pasa
otra vez triste estaba está sentado de
la pena atención que el tono de las
luces son frías aquí hay algo de
frialdad le está cantando como algo o
alguien ausente o perdido en esta
actuación vemos que haya una recreación
y su histrionismo aquí ya es se gusta
porque está cómodo contando la historia
volvemos a ver los ojos llorosos tiene
la respiración acelerada en los puños
los aprietas vamos a escucharlos un
momento a ver qué de qué trata
no puedo
[Música]
[Aplausos]
y ahora rafael en esta actuación va a
ser algo firma 100% rafael va a hacer
mutis por el foro se tira del escenario
se va es un recurso actoral muy clásico
y él lo escenifica aquí no puede con la
presión y se va del escenario
evidentemente luego vuelve para deleite
de sus fans y ya la última que os traigo
es un regalo por favor presta atención
porque desde el segundo uno rafael es
capaz de exteriorizar sin necesidad de
hacer nada más con su cuerpo el
contenido de esa canción muy atentos
desde ya
vemos luces multicolores y bailarines
baja muy decidido la escalera se deja
desabrochar el chaleco y cuerpecito de
viernes
está en éxtasis encantado de la vida
hace lo que le da la gana porque puede
y el amor están poseídos
[Aplausos]
lo siento
bien me entendéis un poquito más ahora
verdad bien os acordáis de la frase que
yo os decía de que cuando uno es
excesivo puede conseguir grandes metas
pues esta frase rafael se la ha aplicado
como hemos visto y se la ha aplicado
entre otras cosas porque la frase es
suya la dijo él en un programa de
televisión bien este artista ha
conseguido algo muy importante en el
mundo del espectáculo y es tener
personalidad y estilo propio se puede
diferenciar de cualquier otro cantante
y este este manierismo raphaelista que
os he mostrado lo he hecho hace y ahora
allá donde vaya ya sea en el madison
square garden de nueva york en el teatro
olympia de parís en cualquier teatro o
auditorio de moscú vamos a verlo el mes
que viene aquí en el teatro falla pero
es que actúa de la misma manera los
conciertos duran lo mismo ahora
recortado un poco el tiempo y duran dos
horas y media de la misma manera le da
igual porque él lleva su estilo propio
tan importante
rafael me ha ayudado a transmitir la
importancia de la comunicación no verbal
en apenas unos segundos habéis sido
capaces de deducir el estado de ánimo en
el que se encontraba habéis sacado
deducciones me ha traído
ha causado rechazo risas admiración y
esto es extrapolable a cualquier ámbito
de la vida siendo observadores se gana
muchísimo más que siendo charlatanes os
lo dice una que de pequeña prácticamente
no hablaba pero se fijaba mucho en todo
os invito a que prestáis más y mejor
atención a la comunicación no verbal
comunicamos de manera no verbal las 24
horas del día incluso durmiendo incluso
durmiendo el amor está en el aire y en
la comunicación no verbal también
gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]